The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOSH MCDERMOTT: We're
going to get started again.
So where we stopped,
I had just played you
some of the results of this
text, your synthesis algorithm.
We all agreed that they
sounded pretty realistic.
And so the whole
point of this was
that this gives
plausibility to the notion
that you could be representing
these textures with these sorts
of statistics that you can
compute from a model of what we
think encapsulates
the signal processing
in the early auditory system.
And, again, I'll just
underscore that the sort
of cool thing about
doing the synthesis
is that there's an
infinite number of ways
in which it can fail, right.
And by listening to it
and convincing yourself
that those things actually
sound pretty realistic,
you actually get a
pretty powerful sense
that the representation
is sort of capturing
most of what you hear
when you actually listen
to that natural sound, right?
And for instance, we could
design a classification
algorithm that could
discriminate between all
these different things, right.
But the point is
that they could--
the representation
could still not
capture all kinds of different
things that you would hear.
And by synthesizing,
because of the fact
that you can potentially fail
in any of the possible ways,
right.
And then listen and observe
whether the failure occurs.
You get a pretty
powerful method.
All right.
But one thing that you
might be concerned about.
And this is sort
of something that
was annoying me, right, is
that what we've done here
is we've imposed a whole bunch
of statistical constraints,
right.
So we're measuring like this
really large set of statistics
from the model, right.
And then generating things
that have the same values
of those statistics.
So there's this question of
whether any set of statistics
will do.
And so we wonder
what would happen
if we measured statistics
from a model that
deviates from what we know
about the biology of the ear.
So, in particular, you
remember that in this model
that we set out, there were
a bunch of different stages,
right.
So we've got this initial
stage of bandpass filtering.
There's the process of
extracting the envelope
and then applying
amplitude compression.
And there's this
modulation filtering.
And in each of
these cases, there
are particular characteristics
of the signal processing
of that's explicitly intended
to mimic what we see in biology.
And so in particular as we
noted the kinds of filter banks
that you see in
biological systems
are better approximated
by something
that's logarithmically
spaced than something
that's linearly spaced.
So we remember--
remember that picture
I showed at the start, where
we saw that the filters up
here were a lot broader than the
filters down here, all right.
OK, and so we can
ask, well, what
happens if we swap in a filter
bank that's linearly spaced.
It's sort of more closely
analogous to like an FFT,
for instance.
Similarly we can ask, well, what
happens if we kind of get rid
of this nonlinear function
here that's applied
to the amplitude envelope.
And we make the amplitude
respond to linear instead.
And so we did this.
So you can change
the auditory model
and play the exact same game.
So you can measure
statistics from that model
and synthesize something
from those statistics.
And then ask whether
they sound any different.
And so we did an experiment.
So we would play people
on the original sound.
And from that original sound,
we have two synthetic versions.
One that's generated
from the statistics
of the model that replicates
biology as best we know how.
On the other of it that
is altered in some way.
And we would ask people which
of the two synthetic version
sounds more realistic?
And so there's four
conditions in this experiment
because we could alter these
models in three different ways.
So we could get rid of
amplitude compression--
that's the first bar.
We could make the
cochlea linearly spaced.
Or we could make the modulation
filters linearly spaced.
Or we could do all three, and
that's the last condition.
And so it's being
plotted on this axis--
whoops I gave it away--
is the proportion of
trials on which people
said that the synthesis from
the biologically plausible model
was more realistic.
And so if it doesn't matter
what statistics you use,
you should be right
here at this 50% mark
in each of these cases.
And as you can
see in every case,
people actually report
them, on average,
the synthesis from the
biologically plausible model
is more realistic.
And I'll give you a
couple of examples.
So here's crowd
noise synthesized
from the biologically
plausible auditory model.
[CROWD NOISE]
And here's the result of
doing the exact same thing
but from the altered model.
And this is from this
condition here where
everything is different.
And you, a little here, it
just kind of sounds weird.
[CROWD NOISE]
It's kind of
garbled in some way.
So here's a
helicopter synthesized
from the biologically
plausible model.
[HELICOPTER NOISE]
And here's from the other one.
Sort of-- doesn't sound like
the modulations are quite as
precise.
And so the notion here is that--
we're initializing this
procedure with noise.
And so the output
is a different sound
in every case that
are sharing only
the statistical properties.
And so the statistics
that we measure and used
to do the synthesis,
they define a class
of sounds that include
the original that,
in fact, defines a set as well
as a whole bunch of others.
And when you run the
synthesis, you're
generating one of
these other examples.
And so the notion is that if
the statistics are measuring
what the brain is measuring,
well, then, these examples
ought to sound like another
example of the original sound.
You ought to be generating
sort of an equivalence class.
And the idea is that
when you are synthesizing
from statistics of this
non-biological model
where it's a
different set, right?
So, again, it's defined
by the original.
But it contains
different things.
And they don't sound
like the original
because they're
presumably not defined
with the measurements
that the brain is making.
I just mentioned to you
the fact that the procedure
will generate a different
signal in each of these cases.
Here you can see the
result of synthesizing
from the statistics of a
particular recording of waves.
These are three
different examples.
And if you sort
of inspect these,
you can kind of see that
they're all different, right?
They sort of have
peaks and amplitude
in different places and stuff.
But on the other
hand, they all kind of
look the same in
a sense that they
have the same textural
properties, right?
And that's what's
supposed to happen.
And so the fact that you have
all of these different signals
that have the same
statistical properties
raises this interesting
possibility,
which is that if the brain is
just representing time average
statistics, we would predict
that different exemplars
of a texture ought to be
difficult to discriminate.
And so this is the thing
that I'll show you about next
is an experiment that
attempts to test whether this
is the case to try to
test whether, really, you
are, in fact, representing these
textures with statistics that
summarize their properties
by averaging over time.
And in doing so, we're
going to take advantage
of a really simple
statistical phenomenon, which
is that statistics that are
measured from small samples
are more variable than
statistics measured
from large samples.
And that's what is exemplified
by the graph that's
here on the bottom.
So what this graph is
plotting is the results
of an exercise where we took
multiple excerpts of a given
texture of a
particular duration.
So you're 40 milliseconds,
80, 160, 320.
So we get a whole bunch
of different excerpts
of that length.
And then we measure a particular
statistic from that excerpt.
So in this case it's a
particular cross correlation
coefficient for the envelopes
of a pair of sub-bands.
So we're going to
measure that statistic
in those different excerpts.
And then we're just going to
try to see how variable that
is across excerpts.
And that's summarized
with a standard deviation
of the statistic.
And that's what's plotted
here on the y-axis.
And so the point is that
when the excerpts are short,
the statistics are variable.
So you measure it in one excerpt
and then another and then
another.
And you don't get the
same thing, all right.
And so the standard
deviation is high.
And as the excerpt
duration increases,
the statistics become
more consistent.
They converge to the true
values of the station underlying
stationary process.
And so the standard
deviation kind of shrinks.
All right, and so
we're going to take
advantage of this in the
experiments that we'll do.
All right, so first
to make sure that
or to give plausibility
to the notion
that people might
be able to base
judgments on
long-term statistics,
we ask people to discriminate
different textures.
So these are things that have
different long-term statistics.
And so in the
experiment, people would
hear three sounds,
one of which would
be from a particular
texture like rain.
And then two others
of which would
be different examples
of a different texture
like a stream.
So you'd hear a rain--
stream one-- stream too.
And the task was to
say which sound was
produced by a different source.
And so in this case, the
answer would be first--
all right.
And so we gave people this task.
And we manipulated the
duration of the excerpts.
And so the notion here is that
while given this graph, what
happens is that the
statistics are very
variable for short excerpts.
And then they become more
consistent as the excerpt
duration gets longer.
And so if you're
basing your judgments
on the statistics computed
across the excerpt,
well, then you
ought to get better
at seeing whether
the statistics are
the same or different as the
excerpt duration gets longer.
All right, and so what
we're going to plot here
is the proportion correct
that this task is a function
of the excerpt duration.
And, indeed, we see
that people get better
as the duration gets longer.
So they're not very
good when you give them
a really short clip.
But they get better and better
and as the duration increases.
Now, of course, this is not
really a particularly exciting
result. When you
increase the duration,
you give people
more information.
And pretty much on
any story, people
ought to be getting
better, right?
But it's at least
consistent with the notion
that you might be basing
your judgments on statistics.
Now the really critical
experiment is the next one.
And so in this experiment, we
gave people different excerpts
of the same texture.
And we asked of them
to discriminate them.
So again on each trial,
you hear three sounds.
But they're all excerpts
from the same texture.
But two of them are identical.
So in this case,
the last two are
physically identical excerpts
of, for instance, rain.
And the first one is a
different excerpt of rain.
And so you just have
to say, which one is
different from the other two?
All right, now but maybe
the null hypothesis here
is what you might
expect if you gave this
to a computer algorithm that was
just limited by sensor noise.
And so the notion is that as the
excerpt duration gets longer,
you're giving people
more information
with which to tell that this
one is different from this one.
So maybe if you listen
to just the beginning,
it would be hard.
But as you got more information,
it would get easier and easier.
If in contrast you think that
what people represent when they
hear these sounds are statistics
that summarize the properties
over time.
Well, I've just shown you
how the statistics converge
to fixed values as the
duration increases.
And so if what people
are representing
are those statistics,
you might paradoxically
think that as the
duration increases,
they would get
worse at this task--
all right.
And that's, in fact,
what we find happened.
So people are good
at this task when
the excerpts are very short
on the order of, like, 100
milliseconds.
So they can very easily
tell you whether you're--
which of the two
excerpts is different.
And then as the duration
gets longer and longer,
they get progressively
worse and worse.
And so we think this is
consistent with the idea
that when you are hearing a
texture, once the texture is
a couple of seconds long, you're
predominantly representing
the statistical
properties averaging
the properties over time.
And you lose access to the
details that differentiate
different examples of rain
so that the exact positions
of the rain drops or the clicks
of the fire, what have you.
Why should people be
unable to discriminate
two examples of rain?
Well, you might think,
well, these textures
are just homogeneous, right?
There's just not enough stuff
there to differentiate them.
And we know that
that's not true,
because if you just chop out
a little section at random,
people can very easily
tell you whether it's
the same or different, right.
So at a local time
scale, the details
is very easily discriminable.
You might also imagine
that what's happening
is that over time, maybe there's
some kind of masking in time.
Or that the representation
kind of gets
blurred together in
some strange way.
On the other hand,
when you give people
sounds that have
different statistics,
you find that they're
just great, right.
So they get better and better
as the stimulus increases.
And, in fact, the fact that
they continue to get better,
that seems to indicate
that the detail that
is streaming into
your ears is being
accrued into some representation
that you have access to.
And so we think what
we think is happening
is that those details come in.
They're incorporated into
your statistical estimates.
But the fact that you can't tell
apart these different excerpts
means that there's these details
are not otherwise retained.
All right, so they're
accrued into statistics,
but then you lose access to
the details on their own.
The point is that the result
as it stands, I think,
provides evidence for a
representation of time average
statistics.
So that is that when the
statistics are different,
you can tell things
are distinct.
When they're the same,
you can't, and relates
to this phenomenon of the
variability of statistics
as a function of sample size.
So a couple control experience
that are probably not
exactly addressing
the question you just
raised but maybe are related.
So one obvious possibility is
that the reason that people
are good at the
exemplar discrimination
here when the excerpts
are short and bad
here might be the fact
that maybe your memory is
decaying with time.
All right, so the way that we
did this experiment originally
was that there was a fixed
inner stimulus interval,
so that was the same.
It was couple of hundred
milliseconds in every case.
And so to tell that this is
different from this, the bits
that you would have to compare
are separated by a shorter time
interval than they
are in this case,
right, where they're separated
by a longer time interval.
And if you might just imagine
that memory decays with time,
you might think that
would make people worse.
So we did a control
experiment where we equated
the inner onset interval.
All right, so that
the elapsed time
between the stuff that you
would have to compare in order
to tell whether
something was different
was the same in the two cases.
And that basically makes
no difference, right.
You're still a lot better
when the things are
short than when they're long.
And we went to
pretty great lengths
to try to help
people be able to do
this with these long excerpts.
So you might also
wonder, well, given
that you can do this
with the short excerpts.
With the short
excerpts are really
just analogous to the very
beginning of these longer
excerpts.
All right, so why can't you
just listen to the beginning?
And so we tried to help
people do just that.
So in this condition
here, we put
a little gap between the
very beginning excerpt
and the rest of
the thing, right?
And we just told
people, all right,
there's going to be this
little thing at the start--
just listen for that.
And people can't do that.
So we also did it at the end--
so if at the gap at the end.
So again, you get this little
thing of the same length
as you have in the
short condition.
And this is performance,
in this case,
some people are good when
it's short and a lot worse
when it's longer.
And the presence of
a gap doesn't really
seem to make a
difference, right.
So you have great trouble
accessing these things.
Another thing that's sort
of relevant and related
was these experiments
that resulted
from our thinking about the
fact that textures are normally
not generated from our
synthesis algorithm,
but rather from the
super position of lots
of different sources.
And so we wondered what would
happen to this phenomenon
if we varied the number
of sources in a textures.
So we actually
generated textures
by superimposing different
numbers of sources.
So in one case we did
this with speakers.
So we wanted to get rid
of linguistic effects.
And so we used German
speech and people
that didn't speak German.
So it was like a
German cocktail party
that we're going to generate.
So we have one person like this.
[FEMALE VOICE 1]
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
And then 29--
[GROUP VOICE] [SPEAKING GERMAN]
All right, room full of people
speaking German, all right?
And so we do the
exact same experiment
where we give people different
exemplars of these textures.
And we ask them to
discriminate between them.
And so what's plotted here
is the proportion correct
is a function of duration.
Here, we've reduced it to just
two durations-- short and long.
And there's four
different curves
corresponding to different
numbers of speakers
in that signal, right.
So the cyan here is what
happens with a single speaker.
And so with a single
speaker, you actually
get better at doing this
as the duration increases.
All right, and so
that's, again, consistent
with the null hypothesis that
when there's more information,
you're actually
going to be better
able to say whether something
is the same or different.
But as you increase the number
of people at the cocktail
party--
the density of the
signal in some sense--
you can see that performance
for the short excerpts
doesn't really change.
So you retain the ability to
say whether these things are
the same or different.
But there's this
huge interaction.
And for the long excerpts, you
get kind of worse and worse.
So impairment at
long durations is
really specific to
textures-- doesn't seem to be
present for single sources.
To make sure that phenomenon is
not really specific to speech,
we did the exact same thing
with synthetic drum hits.
So we just varied the density
of a bunch of random drum hits.
Like, here's five
hits per second.
[DRUM SOUNDS]
Here's 50.
All right, and you see
the exact same phenomenon.
So for the very
sparsest case, you
get better as you go from the
short excerpts to the long.
But then as the
density increases,
you see this big interaction.
And you get
selectively worse here
for the long duration case.
OK, so, again, it's
worth pointing out
that the high performance
with the short excerpts
indicate that all the stimuli
have discriminable variation.
So it's not the case that
these things are just
like totally homogeneous.
And that's why you can't do it.
It seems to be a specific
problem with retaining
temporal detail when the signals
are both long and texture-like.
OK, so what does this mean?
Well, go ahead.
Here's the specular framework.
And this sort of gets
back to these questions
about working
memory, and so forth.
And so this the way that I
make sense of this stuff.
And each one of these things
is pure speculation or almost
pure speculation.
But I actually think
you need all of them
to really totally make
sense of the results.
It's at least interesting
to think about.
So I think it's
plausible that sounds
are encoded both as sequences
of features and with statistics
that average
information over time.
And I think that the features
with which we encode things
are engineered to be sparse for
typical natural sound sources.
But they end up being
dense for textures.
So the signal comes
in-- you're trying
to model that with a whole
bunch of different features
that are in some dictionary
you have in your head.
And for a signal like speech,
your dictionary features
include things that might
be related to phonemes
and so forth.
And so for like a
single person talking,
you end up with
this representation
that's relatively sparse.
It's got sort of a small
number of feature activations.
But when you get a
texture, in order
to actually model
that signal, you
need lots and lots and lots
of feature coefficients,
all right, in order to
actually model the signal.
And my hypothesis would
be that memory capacity
places limits on the number of
features that can be retained.
All right, so it's
not really related
to the duration of signal
that you can encode, per se.
It's on the number
of coefficients
that you can retain that you
need to encode that signal.
And the additional thing
I would hypothesize
is that sound is continuously,
and this is critical
obligatorily encoded.
All right, so this stuff
comes into your ears.
You're continuously
projecting it
onto this dictionary of features
that you have-- all right.
And you've got
some memory buffer
within which you can hang onto
some number of those features.
But then once the memory
buffer gets exceeded,
it gets overwritten.
And so you just lose all
the stuff that came before.
So when your memory capacity
for these future sequences
is reached, the
memory is overwritten
by the incoming sound.
And the only thing you're left
with are these statistics.
So I'll give you one last
experiment in the texture
domain, and then we'll move on.
So this is an experiment
where we presented people
with an original recording,
and then the synthetic version
that we generated from the
the synthesis algorithm.
And we just ask them
to rate the realism
of the synthetic example.
And so this is just a summary of
the results of that experiment
where we did this for
170 different sounds.
And this is a histogram of
the average realism rating
for each of those 170 sounds.
And there's just two points
to take away from this, right.
The first that there's
a big peak up here.
So they rate it as the
realism on a scale of 1 to 7.
And so the big
peak looks centered
at 6 means that the synthesis
is working pretty well
most of the time.
And that's sort of encouraging.
But there's this other
interesting thing,
which is that there's this
long tail down here, right.
And what this means is
that people are telling us
that this synthetic signal
that is statistically
matched to this
original recording
doesn't sound anything like it.
And that's really interesting
because it's statistically
matched to the original.
So it's matched in all these
different dimensions, right.
And, yet, there's still things
that are perceptually missing.
And that tells us
that there are things
that are important to the brain
that are not in our model.
This is a list of the
15 or so sounds that
got the lowest realism ratings.
And just to make
things easy on you,
I'll put labels next to them.
Because by and large, they
tend to fall into sort
of three different categories--
sounds that have some
sort of pitch in them.
Sounds that have some kind
of rhythmic structure.
And sounds that
have reverberation.
And I'll play you
these examples,
because they're really kind
of spectacular failures.
Here, I'll play the original
version and then the synthetic.
[RAILROAD CROSSING SOUNDS]
And here's the synthetic.
I'm just warning you-- it's bad.
[SYNTHETIC RAILROAD CROSSING
SOUNDS]
Here's the tapping rhythm--
really simple but--
[TAPPING RHYTHM SOUNDS]
And the synthetic version.
[SYNTHETIC TAPPING RHYTHM
SOUNDS]
All right.
This is what happens if you--
well, this is not going to
work very well because we're
in an auditorium.
But I'll try it anyways.
This is a recording of somebody
running up a stairwell that's
pretty reverberant.
[STAIR STEP SOUNDS]
And here's this
synthetic version.
And it's almost as
though like the echoes
don't get put in the
right place, or something.
[SYNTHETIC STAIR STEP SOUNDS]
And now it sound even worse
if this was not an auditorium.
Here's what happens with music.
[SALSA MUSIC PLAYING]
And the synthetic version.
And this is what
happens with speech.
[MALE VOICE 1] A boy
fell from the window.
The wife helped her husband.
Big dogs can be dangerous.
Her-- [INAUDIBLE].
All right, OK, so
in some sense, this
is the most
informative thing that
comes out of this whole
effort, because, again, it
makes it really clear what
you don't understand-- right.
And in all these cases, it was
really not obvious, a priori,
that things would be this bad.
I actually thought it
was sort of plausible
that we might be
able to capture pitch
with some of these statistics.
Same with reverb and certainly
some of these simple rhythms.
I kind of thought that
some of the modulation
filters responses and
their correlations
would give this to you.
And it's not until you actually
test this with synthesis
that you realize how
bad this is, right?
And so this really
kind of tells you
that there's something
very important
that your brain is
measuring that we just
don't yet understand and hasn't
been built into our model.
So it really sort of identifies
the things you need to work on.
OK, so just take home
messages from this portion
of the lecture.
So I've argued that
sound synthesis is
a powerful tool that can help
us test and explore theories
of addition and that
the variables that
produce compelling synthesis
are things that could plausibly
underlie perception.
And, conversely, that
synthesis failures
are things that point the
way to new variables that
might be important for
the perceptual system.
I've also argued that textures
are a nice point of entry
for a real world hearing.
I think what's appealing about
them is that you can actually
work with actual real
world-like signals and all
of the complexity that at
least exists in that domain.
And, yet, work with
them and generate things
that you feel like
you can understand.
And I've argued that
many natural sounds may
be recognized with
relatively simple statistics
of early auditory
representation.
So the very simplest kinds of
statistical representations
that you might construct
that capture things
like the spectrum.
Well, that on its own is
not really that informative.
But if you just go a
little bit more complex
and into the domain of marginal
moments and correlations,
you get representations
that are pretty powerful.
And finally, I gave
you some evidence
that for textures
of moderate length,
statistics may be
all that we retain.
So there are a lot of
interesting open questions
in this domain.
So one of the big ones,
I think, is the locus
of the time-averaging.
So I told you about how we've
got some evidence in the lab
that the time scale
of the integration
process for computing
statistics is
on the order of several seconds.
And that's a really
long time scale
relative to typical time
scales in the auditory system.
And so where exactly that
happens in the brain,
I think, is very much an
open question and kind
of an interesting one.
And so we'd like
to sort of figure
out how to get some
leverage on that.
There's also a lot of
interesting questions
about the relationship
to scene analysis.
So usually you're not hearing
a texture in isolation.
It's sort of the
background to things
that, maybe, you're actually
more interested in-- somebody
talking or what not.
And so the relationship
between these statistical
representations and the
extraction of individual source
signals is something
that's really open,
and, I think, kind
of interesting.
And then these other questions
of what kinds of statistics
would you need to account
for some of these really
profound failures of synthesis.
OK, so actually one--
I think this might be
interesting to people.
So I'll just talk
briefly about this.
And then we're going to
have to figure out what
to do for the last 20 minutes.
But one of the
reasons, I think, I
was requested to talk about
this is because of the fact
that there's been all
this work on texture
in the domain of vision.
And so it's sort of an
interesting case where
we can kind of think about
similarities and differences
between sensory systems.
And so back when we
were doing this work--
as I said, this was joint
work with Eero Simoncelli.
I was a post-doc
in his lab at NYU.
And we thought it would
be interesting to try
to turn the kind of standard
model of visual texture, which
was done by Javier
Portia and Eero
a long time ago, into sort
of the same kind of diagram
that I've been showing you.
And so we actually
did this in our paper.
And so this is the one that
you've been seeing all talk,
right.
So you've got a
sound-wave form--
a stage of filtering.
This non-linearity to extract
the envelope and compress it.
And then another
stage of filtering.
And then there are
statistical measurements
that kind of the last two
stages of representation.
And this is an analogous
diagram that you
can make for this sort of
standard visual texture model.
So we start out with
images like beans.
There's centers surround
filtering of the sort
that you would find
in the retina or LGN
that filters things into
particular spatial frequency
bands.
And so that's what you get here.
So these are sub-bands again.
Then there's oriented
filtering of the sort
that you might get via
simple cells and V1.
So then you get the sub-bands
divided up even finer
into both spatial
frequency and orientation.
And then there's
something that's
analogous to the extraction
of the envelope that
would give you something
like a complex cell.
All right, and so this is
sort of local amplitude
in each of these different
sub-bands-- right.
So you can see, here, the
contrast is very high.
And so you get a high response
in this particular point
in the sub-band.
So, again, this is in
the dimensions of space.
So that's a difference,
right, so it's an image.
So you got x and
y-coordinates instead of time.
But, again, there are
statistical measurements,
and you can actually
relate a lot of them
to some of the same
functional form.
So there's marginal
moments just like we
were computing from sound.
In the visual texture model,
there's an auto correlation.
So that's measuring
spatial correlations
which we don't actually
have in the auditory model.
But then these correlations
across different frequency
channels.
So this is across different
spatial frequencies
to things tuned to
the same orientation.
And this is across orientations
and in the energy domain.
So a couple of
interesting points
to take from this
if you just sort of
look back and forth
between these two pictures.
The first is that the
statistics that we ended up
using in the domain of sound
are kind of late in the game.
All right, so they're sort of
after this non-linear stage
that extracts amplitude.
Whereas in the
visual texture model,
the nonlinearity happens here.
And there's all
these statistics that
are being measured at
these earlier stages
before you're extracting
local amplitude.
And that's an
important difference,
I think, between
sounds and images
and that a lot of
the action and sound
is in the kind of the
local amplitude domain.
Whereas there's a lot of
important structure and image--
images that has to do
with sort of local phase
that you can't just get
from kind of local amplitude
measurements.
But at sort of a coarse
scale, the big picture
is that we think
of visual texture
as being represented with
statistical measurements
that average across space.
And we've been arguing
that sound texture consists
of statistical computations
that average across time.
That said, as I was
alluding to earlier,
I think it's totally plausible
that we should really
think about visual texture as
something that's potentially
dynamic if you're looking at
a sheet blowing in the wind
or much of people
moving in a crowd.
And so there might well be
statistics in the time domain
as well that people just
haven't really thought about.
OK, so auditory
scene analysis is,
loosely speaking, the
process of inferring events
in the world from sound, right.
So in almost any kind
of normal situation,
there is this sound signal
that comes into your ears.
And that's the result of
multiple causal factors
in the world.
And those can be different
things in the world that
are making sound.
As we discussed,
the sound signal
also interacts with the
environment on the way
to your ear.
And so both of those
things contribute.
The classic
instantiation of this
is the cocktail
party problem where
the notion is that
there would be
multiple sources in the world
that the signals from the two
sources sum together into a
mixture that enters your ear.
And as a listener,
you're usually
interested in individual
sources, maybe,
one of those in particular
like what somebody that you
care about is saying.
And so your brain has to
take that mixed signal--
and from that to infer
the content of one or more
of the sources.
And so this is the
classic example
of an ill-posed problem.
And by that I mean
that it's ill-posed
because many sets
of possible sounds
add up to equal the
observed mixture.
So all you have access to
is this red guy here, right?
And you'd like to infer
that the blue signals,
which are the true sources
that occurred in the world.
And the problem is that there
are these green signals here,
which also add up
to the red signal.
In fact, there's lots and
lots and lots of these, right?
So your brain has to
take the red signal
and somehow infer the blue ones.
And so this is analogous
to me telling you,
x plus y equals 17--
please solve for x.
And so, obviously, if you
got this on a math test,
you would complain because
there is not a unique solution,
right.
That you could have 1 in 16,
and 2 in 15, and 3 in 14,
and so on and so forth, right?
But that's exactly the
problem that your brain
is solving all the
time every day when
you get a mixture of sounds.
And the only way that you can
solve problems of these sorts
is by making assumptions
about the sound sources.
And the only way that you would
be able to make assumptions
about sound sources is if
real-world sound sources
have some degree of regularity.
And in fact, they do.
And one easy way to see
this is by generating sounds
that are fully random.
And so the way that
you would do this
is you would have a
random number generator--
you would draw
numbers from that.
And each of those numbers
would form a particular sample
and a sound signal.
And then you could play that
and listen to it, right.
And so if you did
that procedure,
this is what you would get.
[SPRAY SOUNDS]
All right, so those are
fully random sound signals.
And so we could generate
lots and lots of those.
And the point is that
with that procedure,
you would have to
sit there generating
these random sounds for
a very, very long time
before you got something that
sounded like a real world
sounds, right?
Real world sounds are like this.
[ENGINE SOUND]
Or this--
[DOOR BELL SOUND]
[BIRD SOUND]
Or this--
[SCRUBBING SOUND]
All right, so the
point is that the set
of sounds that
occur in the world
are a very, very,
very small portion
of the set of all physically
realizable sound-wave forms.
And so the notion is that that's
what enables you to hear it.
It's the fact that you've
instantiated the fact
that the structure of real
world tones is not random.
And such that when you
get a mixture of sounds,
you can actually make
some good guesses
as to what the sources are.
All right, so we rely on these
regularities in order to hear.
So one intuitive view of
inferring a target source
from a mixture like
this is that you have
to do at least a couple things.
One is to determine the grouping
of the observed elements
and the sound signal.
And so what I've
done here is for each
of these-- this is that cocktail
party problem demo that we
saw that we heard at the start.
So we've got one speaker--
two, three, and then seven.
And in the spectrograms,
I've coded the pixels
either red or green, where
the pixels are coded red
if they come from something
other than the target source,
right.
So this stuff up here is coming
from this additional speaker.
And then the green bits are
the pixels in the target signal
that are masked by
the other signal.
Or the other signal actually
has higher intensity.
And so one notion
is that, well, you
have to be able to tell
that the red things actually
don't go with the gray things.
But then you also need to take
these parts that are green,
where the other
source is actually
swamping the thing
you're interested in,
and then estimate the
content of the target source.
That's at least a very sort
of naive intuitive view
of what has to happen.
And in both of these cases, the
only way that you can do this
is by taking advantage of
statistical regularities
in sounds.
So one example of
irregularity that we
think might be used to group
sound is harmonic frequencies.
So voices and instruments
and certain other sounds
produce frequencies that
are harmonics, i.e.,
multiples of a fundamental.
So here's a schematic
power spectrum
of somebody of what might
come out of your vocal chords.
So there's the fundamental
frequency here.
And then all the
different harmonics.
And they exhibit this
very regular structure.
Here, similarly, this
is A440 on the oboe.
[OBOE SOUND]
So the fundamental
frequency is 440 hertz.
That's concert A.
But if you look
at the power spectrum
of that signal,
you get all of these integer
multiples of that fundamental.
All right, and so the way
that this happens in speech
is that there are these--
your vocal chords,
which open and closed
in this periodic manner.
They generate a series
of sound pulses.
And in the frequency
domain, that
translates to
harmonic structure.
Not going to go through
this in great detail.
Hynek's going to tell
you about speech.
All right, and so there's
some classic evidence
that your brain uses harmonicity
as a grouping cue, which
is that if you take a series
of harmonic frequencies
and you mistune one of
them, your brain typically
causes you to hear that
as a distinct sound source
once the mistuning
becomes sufficient.
And here's just a
classic demo of that.
[MALE VOICE 2] Demonstration
18-- isolation of a frequency
component based on mistuning.
You are to listen for the third
harmonic of a complex tone.
First, this component is
played alone as a standard.
Then over a series
of repetitions,
it remains at a
constant frequency
while the rest of the
components are gradually lowered
as a group in steps of 1%.
[BEEPING SOUNDS]
[MALE VOICE 2] Now after two--
OK, and so what you
should have heard--
and you can tell me whether
this is the case or not--
is that as this thing is
mistuned, at some point,
you actually start to
hear, kind of, two beeps.
All right, there's
the main tone and then
there's this other
little beep, right.
And if you did it in
the other direction,
it would then reverse.
OK, so one other consequence
of harmonicity is--
and somebody was asking
about this earlier--
is that your brain is able to
use the harmonics of the sound
in order to infer its pitch.
So the pitch that you hear
when you hear somebody talking
is like a collective function
of all the different harmonics.
And so one
interesting thing that
happens when you
mistune a harmonic
is that for very
small mistunings,
that initially causes a
bias in the perceived pitch.
And so that's
what's plotted here.
So this is a task where somebody
hears this complex tone that
has one of the harmonics
mistuned by a little bit.
And then they hear
another complex tone.
And they have to adjust
the pitch of the other one
until it sounds the same.
All right, and so what's
being plotted on the y-axis
in this graph is
the average amount
of shift in the pitch match
as a function of the shift
in that particular harmonic.
And for very small
mistunings of a few percent,
you can see that there's
this linear increase
in the proceeded pitch.
All right, so the
mistune that harmonic
causes the pitch to change.
But then once the mistuning
exceeds a certain amount,
you can actually see
that the effect reverses.
And the pitch shift goes away.
And so we think
what's happening here
is that the mechanism
in your brain that
is computing pitch
from the harmonics
somehow realizes that one of
those harmonics is mistuned
and is not part
of the same thing.
And so it's excluded from
the computation of pitch.
So the fact that you segregated
those sources then somehow
happened prior to or
in at the same time
as the calculation of the pitch.
Here's another
classic demonstration
of sounds variations
related to harmonicity.
This is called the
Reynolds-McAdams Oboe--
some collaboration between Roger
Reynolds and Steve McAdams.
There's a complex tone--
and what's going
to happen here is
that the even harmonics-- two,
four, six, eight, et cetera,
will become frequency modulated
in a way that's coherent.
And so, initially, you'll
hear this kind of one thing.
And then it will sort of
separate into these two voices.
And it's called the
oboe because the oboe
is an instrument that has a lot
of power at the odd harmonics.
And so you'll hear
something that
sounds like an oboe along
with something that, maybe, is
like a voice that has vibrato.
[OBOE AND VIBRATO SOUNDS]
Is that work for everybody?
So all these things
that are being affected
in kind of interesting ways by
the reverb in this auditorium,
which will--
yeah, but that mostly works.
So we've done a
little bit of work
trying to test whether the brain
uses harmonicity to segregate
actual speech.
And so very
recently, it's become
possible to manipulate speech
and change its harmonicity.
And I'm not going to tell
you in detail how this works.
But we can resynthesize
speech in ways that
are either harmonic like this.
This sounds normal.
[FEMALE VOICE 2] She
smiled and the teeth
gleamed in her beautifully
modeled olive face.
But we can also resynthesize
it so as to make it inharmonic.
And if you look at
the spectrium here,
you can see that the harmonic
spacing is no longer regular.
All right, so we've
just added some jitter
to the frequencies
of the harmonics.
And it makes it sound weird.
[FEMALE VOICE 2] She
smiled and the teeth
gleamed in her beautifully
modeled olive face.
But it's still perfectly
intelligible, right.
And that's because the
vocal tract filtering
that I think Hynek
is probably going
to tell you about this
afternoon remains unchanged.
And so the notion here is
that if you're actually
using this harmonic
structure to kind of tell you
what parts of the sound
signal belong together-- well,
and if you've got a mixture
of two speakers that
were in harmonic,
you might think
that it would be harder to
understand what was being said.
So he gave people this
task where we played them
words, either one word at a
time, or two concurrent words.
And we just asked them to
type in what they heard.
And then we just score
how much they got correct.
And we did this with a bunch
of different conditions
where we increased the jitters.
So there's harmonic--
[MALE VOICE 3]
Finally, he asked,
do you object to petting?
I don't know why my
Rh has this example.
But, whatever-- it's
taken from a corpus
called TIMIT that has a
lot of weird sentences.
[MALE VOICE 3]
Finally, he asked,
do you object to petting?
Finally, he asked, do
you object to petting?
All right, so it kind of gets
stranger and stranger sounding
than a bottom's out.
These are ratings of
how weird it sounds.
And these are the results of
the recognition experiment.
And so what's being
plotted is the mean number
of correct words as a
function of the deviation
from harmonicity.
So 0 here is perfectly harmonic,
and this is increasing jitter.
And so the interesting
thing is that there's
no effect on the recognition
of single words, which
is below ceiling, because
these are single words that
are excised from sentences.
And so they are actually
not that easy to understand.
But when you give
people pairs of words,
you see that they get worse
at recognizing what was said.
And then the effect
kind of bottoms out.
So this is consistent
with the notion
that your brain is
actually relying, in part,
on the harmonic structure
of the speech in order
to pull, say, two
concurrent speakers apart.
And the other thing
to note here, though,
is that the effect is
actually pretty modest, right.
So you're going from, I
don't know, this is like,
0.65 words correct on
a trial down to 0.5.
So it's like a 20% reduction.
And the mistuning thing
also works with speech.
This is kind of cool.
So here we've just
taken a single harmonic
and mistuned it.
And if you listen to that,
I think this is this--
you'll basically-- you'll
hear the spoken utterance.
And then it will sound
like there's some whistling
sound on top of it.
Because that's what the
individual harmonic sounds
like on its own.
[FEMALE VOICE 3] Academic Act
2 guarantees your diploma.
So you might have
been able to hear--
I think this is the--
[WHISTLING SOUND]
That's a little quiet.
But if you listen again.
[FEMALE VOICE 3] Academic Act
2 guarantees your diploma.
Yeah, so there's this
little other thing
kind of hiding there
in the background.
But it's kind of hard to hear.
And that's probably because
it's particularly in speech
there's all these
other factors that
are telling you
that thing is speech
and that belongs together.
And, all right, let
me just wrap up here.
So there's a bunch of other
demos of this character
that I could kind
of give you about--
I could tell you about.
Another thing that actually
matters is repetition.
So if there's something
that repeats in the signal,
your brain is very strongly
biased to actually segregate
that from the background.
So this is a demonstration
of that in action.
So what I'm going to
be presenting you with
is a sequence of mixtures
of sounds that will
vary in how many there are.
And then at the
end, you're actually
going to hear the target sound.
So if I just give you one--
[WHOPPING SOUND]
All right, it doesn't sound--
the sound at the end
doesn't sound like what
you heard in the first thing.
But, here, you can probably
start to hear something.
[WHOPPING SOUND]
And with here, you'll hear more.
And with here, it's pretty easy.
[WHOPPING SOUND]
All right, so each time you're
getting one of these mixtures--
and if you just get
a single mixture,
you can't hear anything, right.
But just by virtue of the
fact that there is this latent
repeating structure in there.
Your brain is
actually able to tell
that there's a consistent
source and segregates that
from the background.
I started off by telling you
that the only way that you
can actually solve
this problem is
by incorporating your knowledge
of the statistical structure
of the world.
And, yet, so far the way that
the field has really moved
has been to basically
just use intuitions.
And so people would
look at spectrograms
and they say, oh yeah,
there's harmonic structure.
There's common onset.
And so then you can do
an experiment and show
that has some effect.
But what we'd really
like to understand
is how these so-called grouping
cues relate to natural sound
statistics.
We'd like to know
whether we're optimal
given the nature of
real world sounds.
We'd like to know whether
these things are actually
learned from
experience with sound--
whether you're born with them.
The relative importance
of these things
relative to knowledge of
particular sounds like words.
And so this-- I really regard
this stuff as in its infancy.
But I think it's really
kind of wide open.
And so the sort of
take-home messages
here are that there
are grouping cues
that the brain uses to
take the sound energy that
comes into your ears and assign
it to different sources that
are presumed to be related
to statistical regularities
of natural sounds.
Some of the ones
that we know about
are, chiefly, harmonicity and
common onset and repetition.
I didn't really get to this.
But we also know that the brain
infers parts of source signals
that are masked
by other sources,
again, using prior assumptions.
But we really need a proper
theory in this domain,
I think, both to be able
to predict and explain
real world performance.
And also, I think, to be able
to relate what humans are doing
this domain to the
machine algorithms
that we'd like to able to
develop to sort of replicate
this sort of competence.
And the engineering-- there was
sort of a brief period of time
where there were some
people in engineering that
were kind of trying to
relate things to biology.
But by and large, the fields
have sort of diverged.
And I think they really
need to come back together.
And so this is going
to be a good place
for bright young people to work.